Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here is a caller dipping us further into
the black hole of Spanish pronunciations
that I sometimes do on the show.
Speaker 6: David. Sir, this is a reply
to your discussion of the pronunciation
of Spanish language words. Please.
In my. It's a no win situation. I have a friend
elitists that want this right who is originally
from Chile. Yet he often argues with my friend
in Nashville, Delgado, who is from Mexico. Right,
about who is the best chess player in history.
Felipe believes it is Jose Capablanca. Right.
But Iniesta disagrees. So what are you going to
do? Right. In the end, though, they were able to
settle their differences over some database,
a enchilada. So all's well that ends well,
I suppose. All right. Take care of my friend. Bye.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, I understand that. You know,
it is one of these things where if you say
Capablanca, do. Don't you speak Spanish?
Why? Why are you saying Capablanca? And then if
you say Capablanca, then people say it will do.
That's really jarring. What if you're speaking
English? You don't need to do that. It is an
absolute no when it is the black hole of Spanish
pronunciation. Thank you very much for pointing
it out. We have a great bonus show for you
today, but sadly the stories are not exactly
fun stories. A woman was shot dead in Manhattan
while pushing a baby stroller. Horrifying
story which we will talk about. Four individuals
have already been found and charged in that mass
casualty tractor trailer death from Texas that
I spoke to you about yesterday. And we are going
to compare the sentence handed down, the prison
sentence handed down to Elaine Maxwell compared to
the sentence handed down to our Kelly many writing
in and saying, David, it seems as though our
Kelly got a disproportionately heavy sentence
compared to Maxwell based on what they were
charged with. What's going on here? We're going
to talk about it and more on today's bonus show.
Sign up at join pacman dot com. I will see you on
the bonus show or otherwise on tomorrow's program.